hi I'm Leslie and I'm Matt and we've
been married for seven years and we had
a zero-waste wedding zero waste means
that we try not to generate trash and we
carried that philosophy over to our
wedding I think the decision to have a
zero-waste wedding came about rather
organically as we began to plan for our
wedding the things that we were planning
were zero waste I think one of the most
fun things that we did to make our
wedding zero waste was to make the paper
for our invitations and our save the
dates and we did that by collecting junk
mail we turned that into a pulp and put
it into our bathtub and used a window
screen to pull the pulp out and let that
dry and it became paper
because our wedding was zero-waste we
used a lot of the decor from our home
before we had a kegerator we drank a lot
of bottled beer and we saved the bottle
caps and for place cards my maid of
honor wrote everyone's name on one of
the circles at the wedding that was on a
display table next to a sign that told
people what table to sit up for the
flowers for the wedding we got some of
them from a local farmers market and
then gathered the rest from the local
hillsides near the venue we gathered
produce boxes from our caterer and cut
those to about the size of our menu and
then used repurpose ribbon to tie them
on to the cut produce boxes our caterer
focused on local and organic food and
naturally because we use cloth napkins
and real dishes at home we wanted to
have that same experience at our wedding
one challenge we encountered was storing
the food scraps so that our caterer
could take them back down the mountain
to be composted because we're up in the
mountains we had bears or dogs or
something get into the storage place so
some of our food scraps went to local
animals and some made it back down to be
composted because our wedding was zero
waste we saved a lot of money on
traditional expenditures that we were
then able to use in other ways I think a
lot of it is just deciding that that's
what you're gonna do and then come up
with a solution that works for you it's
never 100 percent perfect you're never
gonna get rid of every single thing it's
the cute you make it as close to perfect
as you can our zero waste lifestyle it
became a little bit more tricky once our
daughter was born but because we had a
lot of principles already in place a lot
of that was able to transfer over with
Oliva and it helps us feel like we're
making a difference in our battle with
climate change and it also saves us a
lot of money
[Music]